[Musique]
je vous rappelle les conditions du vin
serveuse de rapatriement on part à ce
vide on va ramener leurs ressortissants
qui sont restée coincée à delhi dans la
voiture dogues qui aurait dû gel un
parent galets et 80 paires de gants
je crois qu'on protège nos clients il
faut qu'on protège nos personnels il
faut aussi qu'on pense à nous un conte
se protège moi aussi donc le port du
masque obligatoire pendant tout le vol
ici vous n'hésitez pas c'est au moins ça
vous décharge de plein de choses dont
franck 5
adèle 8,8
encore une fois merci d'être là je vous
souhaite à tous un bon on se retrouve
tout à l'heure j'ai très fier de faire
ce vol de porter l'uniforme de la france
parce que passé représente la france a
déjà il ya des centaines d'hommes et de
femmes qui se sont impliqués pour
préparer ce vote parce que mon émission
comme ça c'est pas anodin il faut aller
chercher un avion il faut le préparer
il ya des météores il faut le nettoyer
il ya des gens qui ont fait la sûreté
aussi au sol pour nous et des gens pour
nous emmener fayat et des centaines de
métiers
oui moi je pense qu'on peut être fier du
monde soyez fier aussi de compte je peux
être fier de vous j'adore voler avec
vous je pense même qu'on peut ça veut
dire
là on fait une
pré vol de sécurité en fait on vérifie
la présence des ceintures des idées de
sauvetage chico de sécurité soient non
vérifiées rien dans les coffres à
bagages
donc là nous partons à vide pour aller
chercher donc
on espère le plus de français d'autres
nationalités possible pour pouvoir les
rapatrier le plus rapidement de délits
ça permet de participer dans cette
situation difficile à ramener les
ressortissants je pense qu'il nous
attend de pied ferme
d'après les informations que mon épouse
nous sommes donc
de pied ferme en un an
[Musique]